hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
be going over the elephant gambit I get
quite a few requests from viewers you
could always email me at the chess
website at gmail.com to let me know what
videos you'd like to make but the
elephant gambit is one of the most
requested videos so I thought I'd go
ahead and make a video on that if you're
not too familiar with how it starts pawn
to e4 pawn e5 Knight f3 and then pawn to
d5 here we go right here White has two
different options Y can take here on a
d5 with this pawn or the night can take
on e5 I always like to caveat these
videos at the beginning there are some
gamuts that are more sound than others
the elephant gamete is not the most
sound opening out there there's no
reason to send me feedback telling me
that this is not the best opening out
there you're not gonna see it at the
highest level magnus carlsen is not
going to be rolling this out at the next
World Championship but it is still a
very fun game if there's a lot of room
for white to mess this up
you may even run across it yourself as
white you can see how common this is
this opening right here many players are
playing this all the time you may end up
with someone playing pawn to d5 so just
knowing how to combat that or if you
want to try it out yourself because
you're gonna have so many opportunities
to play this I feel like it is a fun
game and I like gambit and generally
like to be pretty aggressive when I play
so hopefully you guys enjoy this video
now for this video we're going to assume
that White's going to take one of these
ponds they could play something
ridiculous and not but for the most part
people are going to take we're gonna
start looking at the pond taking here on
d5 likes gonna always push down here
it's efore it's hacking this Knight now
the best move for white is to play Queen
to e2 pinning down the pawn the pawn
can't take tonight because this King
would be exposed that would be an
illegal move why it's not always gonna
play this especially if you're playing a
fast game someone's not familiar with
the elephant game it they may feel like
they need to move their knight so we'll
look at the different options Knight to
g5 ESCO going to be the worst you have
the Queen just immediately take right
here but something like Knights a g1
feels just as bad you're giving up so
much momentum in the early part of the
game Knight to f6 this is both attacking
the pawn also defending the square here
on e4 where does white continue from
here you can see no pieces develop
they're already two behind the
eight-ball from that respect you could
see pawn to c4 this feels somewhat
normal trying to control this pawn here
on a d5 white is up the material so you
want to hold on to that but blacks just
needs to be continuously aggressive in
this spot once your opponent moves back
to g1 you have to push forward maybe
Knight to c3 here you can castle on the
King side white may try to blow up the
center of the board go ahead and
exchange that's fine once you move your
pawn from the e-file this now exposes
the e-file so your rook can come over to
e8 anytime you want to you may have an
in-between move Knight to g4 this is
protected by the light squared bishop so
you don't have to worry about the Queen
here this adds a lot of pressure to the
square here on f2 the King is the only
piece that's protecting that so you
could see Knight to h3 this does now
protect the square on f2 but now rook to
e8 you can see all the pressure that
black is putting on white now you may
not see pawn to c4 maybe white tries to
defend with Knight to c3 to finish pawn
attacking this pawn right here go ahead
and take this pawn on d5 now if they
want to capture here that's completely
fine if they don't then you're even in
material and you have a good board
presence in at this hitter let's say
they do decide okay well there's a free
pawn here I've already gone down this
path let's go ahead and keep this
material Queen to e7 is the move this
sets them up to make so many mistakes
because a lot of players will see this
they feel like they're Knights being
attacked and they'll try to defend with
their pawn pawn to d3 makes the most
sense but pawn to f3 is gonna be the
exact same both of those fail because
upon to f5 the Knights being pinned down
the knight can't move and so the knight
is going to fall by the pawn there's
just no way around that
now white may realize that's not the
weight
go could play queen - e - this does stop
the pin right here black just continue
Knight to c6 developments here we'll get
all your pieces developed into the game
now let's say white decides that hey
same thing I gotta get some material I
out I don't want to be passive with just
pawn to d3 or D for get my Bishop out I
may not have time to castle so Knight to
f3 you always want to get your Knights
involved pretty early but now Bishop
down here to G for pinning down the
knight whites in a tough spot right here
how does white continue now has a few
options but maybe pawn to h3 it's
hacking the bishop say hey I gotta get
you out of here black does not mind
exchange of material right here white
really needs to take back with the pawn
if it takes back with this Queen it gets
really tricky because Knight down here
to d4 this is attacking both the Queen
as well as the pawn here on C 2 this is
forking the king and the rook the rook
would fall white also has to worry about
later on pawn to f5 this night here on
d4 is also defending this square here on
f5 which is attacking the knight that's
being pinned down so this is extremely
bad but if the Queen doesn't take and
the pawn takes here then blacks still
gonna play Knight down here to d4
attacking the Queen it's hacking this
pawn here on f3 and preparing for pawn
down to f5 so so many things that white
has to worry about very good for black
now in this position we already looked
at the worst Knight to g5 we also looked
at night - g1 you're not gonna see those
as often just want to make sure that if
you do see a mistake you know how to
capitalize Knight to d4 make sense but
if you see this go ahead and just take
with your queen down on d5 now they
could have a few options one of which
would be Knight to be 5 this is defended
by the bishop this does also attack the
square here on c7 not only is this a
check for King the rook it's also
attacking the Queen as well with that
fork so just be aware if you see this
you are gonna want to bring your Queen
back here I like to
bring it back to d7 it does defend the
square also attacks the night here on b5
so maybe Knight to c3 Knight to f6 this
is going to be a fine game another move
that you could see is pawn to c3 this
does defend the knight right here
white doesn't have a lot of great
options to defend that Square except
just moved the knight entirely Knight to
f6 this does defend the center of the
board
maybe pawn to d3 just go ahead and
exchange that's fine this also opens up
this long efile it's also easier for
black to gives light square bishop
involvement to the game get the knight
here to c6 castle on the Queen side if
he wants to be very aggressive so black
has a lot of options now we can also
come back maybe Knight to d4 is not the
move maybe Knight to e5 if White's going
to move tonight which is not necessarily
the best move but Knight to e5 is going
to be the best same thing go ahead and
take with your Queen down here on d5 now
couple options that you could see a 1
would be to bring the knight back here
to c4 okay
the Queen is attacking the knight the
knight needs to move so it brings you
back here this is defended by the bishop
here on f1 but then you could just see
Knight to c6 just normal development
Knight to c3 and then Queen over here to
f5 you still want to be aggressive this
does open up the door later on if you
want to bring your Bishop down here to
c5 then both your Bishop and a queen are
attacking the f2 square so I'm playing
this type of opening because I'm just
looking for tons of attacks and see if
my opponent will fall for one of those
many times they absolutely do now if we
come back maybe it's not Knight to c4
maybe its pawn to d4 now if you're not
familiar there is a real move called
al-hasan you can actually take with your
pawn right here when it's next to each
other on the 4th rank the first move you
only have one opportunity to do this but
you can go ahead and take I recommend
doing that this also opens up for the
Queen to take the knight the Knights
usually gonna come back they could make
a mistake and not take but usually
they're just gonna come back with their
knight and then Knight to c6 you can see
both sides are equal in material this is
going to be fine so that's what happens
if they take and then they decide to go
ahead and move their Knights early on in
the game now the best move from white is
to play Queen to e2 we talked about this
earlier if you see this go ahead and
play Knight to f6 as we've been playing
before it defends the square also
attacks the d5 square pawn to d3 many
times they'll try to blow up the center
so definitely try this Queen takes on d5
maybe Knight to c3 kicking this Queen
away you can go ahead and play Bishop
down to be 4 this does pin down the
knight can't take the Queen you do want
to get your pieces involved it's quickly
as possible maybe the pawn takes the
pawn here on e4
that's fine Queen down here it's
actually fine if white takes our Queen
Black's gonna have a better position the
knight takes here you can see both sides
are equal in material here but black is
definitely more aggressive they really
shouldn't take with their queen but just
won't let you know you do have a better
game if they do now instead of d3 they
could try something else maybe they
didn't want to blow things up maybe
Knight to c3 is what they want to go
with and I would say this is probably
the best option that they have just
normal development waiting to see how
blacks going to respond Bishop to e7 is
what I would recommend getting ready to
castle on at the King side maybe the
knight takes here on e4 castle on the
King side d4 and then the Queen comes
down takes on d5 there you can see that
black is down a pawn in material will
have to fight back so as we said before
this is not the most sound gambit of all
time not trying to convince anyone that
it is so if white plays optimally the
entire way then you will have to fight
back you'll have some very aggressive
pieces that you can but just know that
white definitely would have a
better game still not the easiest to
find all of those moves especially if
you're not familiar with the elephant
game it'd do just like to point it out
now those were the variations if the
pawn takes here on d5 you'll also see
the knight take on e5 quite regularly
and in this case a lot of people tell
you to play Bishop down to d6 I think
it's kind of boring but it is a very
popular move that you'll see attacking
the knight the Knights gonna have to
move or you're gonna have to defend that
so maybe Knight to g4 if that's the case
pawn takes if you see Knight to c3 which
is the most common move this is I just
want to make sure everyone's aware you
need to play Knight to c6 don't play the
knight to f6 what you're used to playing
because the knight can just take right
here that's not what you want to see the
Queen takes Knight recaptures here on e4
things are not as good as you would like
but after Knight to c6 this doesn't open
up the opportunity for white to make a
mistake because Knight taking on e4 is a
huge mistake now you don't want to play
pawn to f5 it looks like that's good
because you're attacking both the
Knights one of the Knights it's gonna
fall unfortunately white can play Knight
takes D 6 and this is check and so black
has to respond it's not gonna go as well
as you would hope but what black can do
is play Queen to e7 this is pinning down
the night here on e4
no great way to defend this let's say
pawn to e3 doesn't really matter
wherever white goes pawn to f5 is now
the move and one of these Knights is
going to fall you could also see instead
that Knight moving another popular move
would be pawn to d4 this is just happens
more often because people try to control
the center of the board go and take with
your pawn right here and then they could
see different options maybe Bishop comes
here to c4 go ahead and take the knight
if you want to you could also seed
Knight to c3 still go ahead and take the
knight on e5 you could later on played
Knight to f6 to protect this pawn but
those are the main options that
see the main reason I don't want to talk
about too many of the variations from
Bishop to d6 is because that's not my
preferred if you're gonna play a gambit
you're usually playing it because it's
going to be fun or you're really trying
to catch your opponent off guard
and if that's the case I think pawn
taking here on e4 is the way to go
gives you a lot of attacking options one
of the most common moves that you'll see
from here is Bishop to c4 it makes a lot
of sense from white he has both the
Knights and the bishop attacking this
pawn here on f7 so what should black do
the answer is completely ignore the
threat if you're familiar with the
Latvian game it one of my favorite
openings and all of chess it just
decimates white because they do not know
how to play against it correctly so the
correct move and my opinion here is
Queen down to g5 it just puts so much
pressure on your opponent's and now they
can definitely play correctly in the
correct move just so you know as Bishop
takes on f7 you want to check your
opponent black still has a very good
game if white does this but if white
takes here on f7 and says yes this is
defended I'm gonna attack both your rook
and your Queen White is going to crumble
because the threat of Queen down here to
g2 now if the Knights were to continue
let's take the rook here
great I'm gonna go ahead and take with
my queen here on h1 now there's two ways
to defend against this one is cleaning
up here to e2 the other one is Bishop
down to f1 King to F 2 is actually
checkmate now it's gonna take a few
moves to actually get there about Bishop
to g4 King up to 83 doesn't have other
options Queen over here to d1 you can
already see the game is lost the queen
is gone there's no way to even take that
back but from here the Queen is going to
come back it's just a matter of okay how
long can white really have in between
moves before they lose Knight to c6 it
does not really matter if the other day
the bishop comes down here to c5 check
queen up here there is going to be a
checkmate no way to stop that there's a
lot of variations that they could go
from if we come back and say the bishop
comes back here to f1 it's still a very
bad situation for white knight down to
f6 this is an important in-between move
because you don't want your opponent to
play queen up to h5 this does stop that
it also allows protection on this pawn
on e4 still a lot of threats so where
does white go maybe Knight to c3 but
then Bishop down here to h3 this Bishop
is being pinned down a lot of pressure
could also play something like Bishop to
g4 this is defended by the knight so a
lot of good options here now if we come
back and say the queen is coming down
here to g1 or G - maybe the Knights not
going to take the rook comes over here
to f1 better move than the knight taking
over here black doesn't care about this
rook over it on h8 it's not involved
into the game at all
but now Bishop comes down to g4 puts a
lot of pressure on an opponent Bishop
down e - Bishop takes Queen takes and
then the King takes on f7 and black his
up material this is going to be good now
we did say that the best move from white
is to take with the bishop on f7 so I
want to make sure everyone understands
exactly how to play because it's not all
terrible yes you're gonna be in a
chaotic board situation but the goal is
just to get as much material involved
into the game and put your opponent to
the test so King to d8 right here and
hopefully your opponent does something
like Bishop to g8 they feel like they
already have material here so they just
continue to extend you do not care about
all this material because you're just
going to continue and play Queen down to
G - maybe rook to f1 and then rook takes
up here on g8 you can see this is a good
situation for black maybe pawn to d4
defending this night here on e5 you can
see Bishop down to h3 now there
our two pieces attacking this rook here
on f1 things are gonna go extremely good
for black now if we come back instead of
the bishop taking here on g8 does have
some other options could play pawn to d4
this is protecting the knight here
now the Queen's gonna continue come down
to g2 attack rook over here to f1 Knight
to f6 and this starts to put more
pressure on your opponent but you can
see this is a good setup white doesn't
have a lot of huge threats anymore and
black has a lot of active pieces he can
now get his light to her Bishop involved
into the game he gets dark square bishop
involvement to the game if he wants to
later he can get his knight involved a
lot of different options here so that's
why I really enjoy just taking with my
pawn here on e4 because most of the time
they're gonna play Bishop to c4 and if
they don't I still am going to have a
very good game as black so hopefully you
enjoyed the elephant game it it is an
extremely fun opening and you just have
so many opportunities to play it because
if you look at the beginning pawn if
Pawnee for Pawnee 5 9 f3 just happens so
often before I sign off I do want to let
everyone know that for this video we do
have a sponsor I want to take a minute
to recognize them and that is Dollar
Shave Club yes I am talking about that
Dollar Shave Club you may be seeing
their commercials in the past they have
some of the funniest commercials out
there what you may not know is they have
way more product than just shaving they
really have everything you need for your
grooming routine so if you're looking
for showering if you're brushing your
teeth if you are shaving they have
products for you and they deliver them
at a very cheap price and the products
are phenomenal if you haven't tried them
I highly recommend them we will have a
promotion link right below this in the
description you can go to
dollarshaveclub.com
the chess
websites again that link will be in the
video description below if you've ever
just wanted to try them outs I highly
recommend clicking on that link they
have starter sets out there for you to
try so you if want to try out what
they're they're shaving kits they're
premium razor with their shave butter
you can get that for just $5 if you want
their shower kit or if you want their
oral care my favorite toothbrush out on
the market I highly recommend it after
that their refill packages are extremely
cheap couple dollars a month you will
not be disappointed I definitely
recommend checking that out thank you so
much for the Dollar Shave Club for
sponsoring this video
and continues to help support this
channel thank you everyone so much for
watching this video hopefully you
enjoyed it and make sure you check out
the link at dollarshaveclub.com the
chess website